it's great to welcome to the program
today EJ Dionne who is a columnist for
The Washington Post senior fellow at the
Brookings Institution and also author of
Code Red
how progressives and moderates can unite
to save our country so I guess that the
first question is unite to save the
country from who or what right right and
in the first instance it's obviously
trunk trumpism the attack on the rule of
law that we've been seeing a lot very
recently but all through the
administration to turn away from
democracy but it's also to save the
country from a radicalized right and
radicalized Republican party the book is
obviously a very anti-trump book but it
is also very critical of a radical right
that really now dominates the Republican
Party and is driven out all vestiges of
both moderation and back in the day even
some liberalism progressivism that
existed inside the Republican Party and
so I argue that in this circumstance
progressives and moderates and we could
argue about the term moderate I'm
careful in the book to say I know
moderate itself is a vexed term but we
could say the center left and left as
well that they have far more in common
with each other at this moment then they
then they have with anyone on the other
side their differences are much smaller
than their differences with the other
side and a subsidiary argument is that
one of the reasons arguments inside the
Democratic Party can get so fierce is
that people who are on the progressive
side have lost sort of sensible
interlocutor in the Republican Party
that almost all the major conversations
about solving public problems take place
inside the Democratic Party so Obamacare
was a program that was built in part on
ideas developed by the Heritage
Foundation and by Mitt Romney in
Massachusetts and this was cast as
somehow socialist by
the other side and so Democrats are now
having the argument that might in
another era have taken place across
party lines you expand on Obamacare or
do you go to single-payer that's the
kind of argument I make in the book but
I argue to get past this moment both of
the Trump moment end of a radicalized
conservatism progressives and moderates
need to be allied because that's the
only way out of this this morass we're
in
so does that presume this idea of vote
for the Democratic nominee no matter who
they are like is that a related idea to
what you are arguing right I think in
this circumstance there is pretty much
no alternative to that and it's obvious
that there are you know a lot of
Democrats especially after last night
who might have second thoughts about
voting for Michael Bloomberg the
probably is going to be my exact
question because you know and I think
that that will be more difficult I mean
I think it was difficult going into that
debate I think it's even more difficult
coming out of that debate similarly
there are people on the right end if you
will of this broad coalition I'm
describing who have some questions about
Bernie Sanders at this moment I think
the Bloomberg question will be the
harder question for an awful lot of
people both on the left and you know
after the demolition job that Elizabeth
Warren did particularly among
progressive women yeah and you know I've
said I'm not supporting Bloomberg in the
primary but if it's November 3rd and
it's Bloomberg versus Trump I'm voting
for Bloomberg and I've pointed out I
think on Supreme Court justice
selections Bloomberg will make far
better choices than what Trump has
evidenced he would do I've listed a few
things and it doesn't mean I'm any great
fan of him but I know a lot of people in
my audience don't feel that way at all
and might my sort of follow-on question
to this is I believe in and support what
we would call a vigorous debate during
the primary about
which ideas should reign supreme so to
speak but I wonder is there a point at
which it becomes self-destructive in the
eventual general election yeah I am
worried about that I may have noticed I
have a column up today where and this
was here I wrote most of it before the
debate that the kind of demolition-derby
that Democrats are having is leading to
their ignoring right on that stage last
night
what is going on outside it was really
striking how little Trump himself
was mentioned we are really at a
potential constitutional crisis here
with what's going on inside the Justice
Department what has gone on with Roger
stone how all these cases are being
cherry picked on Ukraine and Russia by
by bar these are very disturbing things
it did disturb me that Democrats were
spending so much time sort of settling
their own differences that they didn't
even get to hey we're all here because
we need to put a stop to this you know
on your Bloomberg point I think you're
correct that court appointments on what
his budgets would look like even his tax
program is far more progressive than
anything Republicans had to offer and
his support for both the climate
movements and especially the gun
movements is a real thing he's made a
huge difference there I think that what
we saw last night will raise questions
not only on the left but a lot of other
people saying is this AG is he actually
the strongest candidate to put against
Trump I think that was the argument he
needed to make and clearly last night on
that front was a fail no certainly if
his making billions depended on winning
debates I don't know that he would be
nearly nearly as wealthy as he is was my
reality yeah so now and in terms of when
we've seen in the past elections that
are heavily based around defeating the
incumbent so John Kerry in 2004 against
George W Bush strikes me
one of those there is often the argument
made that you've really got to be voting
for something as opposed to trying to
remove the incumbent that it often
doesn't go well when the main messages
remove the incumbent so do you agree
with that and is that maybe something
that tempers the problem of Trump not
being mentioned that much yesterday
which in a way I found refreshing to
just hear the candidates talk about
something other than Trump well I think
there are two sides to this and maybe we
can take Ronald Reagan as the example
one of my arguments in the book by the
way is that a key reason why there has
been a resurgence of democratic
socialism in the u.s. which by the way
has a long American tradition as I point
out in the book Eugene Debs got 6% of
the boat there were actually 1,200 local
elected officials who were socialists
back in that election the reason why
you've had a revival of democratic
socialism is a reaction to the dominance
of our public conversation by the Reagan
economic consensus and so the rise of
democratic socialism is a reaction
against that but what did Reagan do to
create that long hegemony that long
period of conservative dominance I think
there were two sides of it I think
running against an incumbent who's
unpopular is actually a helpful thing
politically Jimmy Carter was unpopular
and I argue in the book for what I call
the power of negative thinking that when
you looked at what Ronald Reagan built
his program on it started out as a
series of negatives anti-tax
anti-communist anti-government I think
what pulls together this coalition are a
similar set of antes obviously anti
Trump and all the things that represents
you know a the oppression of immigrants
and refugees a you know corporate
corruption cast as populism a host it's
disrespect for within a whole series of
things but also a backlash against a
Republican Party that is simply given up
on public
problem-solving on using government to
address inequality to provide health
insurance a whole series of areas where
they proposed simply retreating cutting
taxes relying entirely on the public
sector but out of that negative comes a
series of positives and if I can just
pick three quick issues that are really
burning issues that raise real
coalition-building possibilities right
now the entire Democratic Party the
entire spectrum from Saturday left
now wants to provide affordable good
health insurance to every American
that's not even debated anymore the
debate is over whether we do it through
a public option and building on
Obamacare or go directly up to
single-payer lord I do not think we
should divide ourselves radically over
the path we could disagree we can debate
the path but we all want to go broadly
in the same direction aoc underscored
that recently with their comments second
one is free college that's not so
radical we used to have it before the
massive under investment in public
education whether we get there in one
step or many steps and let's make sure
this includes not only college but also
training for people who don't want to go
to college in the book I quote Richard
Cordray ran for governor of Ohio
unfortunately he didn't win but I love
this line he said you shouldn't have to
go to college to join the middle class I
think we need to broaden that
conversation but that's got a lot of
possibility and lastly the green new
deal which when you boil the green New
Deal down it is saying that we need
urgently to act on the climate and we
also urgently need to restructure the
economy to make it fairer and we need to
do that partly to address losses that
some groups might suffer from taking
bold action on the climate I think these
are all positives that grow out of all
of those negatives so I guess I am not
worried that a pure antitrump campaign
will lack a positive vision of
because I think you're hearing a lot of
positives in all these in the mess of
all these debates there were actually a
lot of proposals well the book I want to
make clear is not proposing this vague
idea of unity for the sake of unity the
way that we've seen criticized over the
last couple of months as we've seen the
Democratic primary shift it's really a
practical and a sensible perspective on
what it is simply that needs to happen
the book is by EJ Dionne it is called
code read how progressives and moderates
can unite to save our country EJ so
great having you on I appreciate your
time thank you so much I hope we can do
this again